julian cierto williams y corona y si tú
eres la que ama a cantar así que una
pregunta cómo sería su cita ideal espera
no creo que yo sea la que le gusta
cantar pero no hay problema
dios mío lo siento jubilee diez versos
uno cita a ciegas con district as esto
será interesante le veremos a jonathan
que tuviera una cita con diez chicas y
encontrar a la más compatible sin poder
verlas
como crees que puedes conocer a alguien
sin verlo en persona si es una
conversación por teléfono entonces
llegas a conocerla
por eso me encantan los operadores
cuando me llaman porque entonces podemos
conversar y tener una gran plática
pero cuando se trata de fotos solo
deslizas para ver quién te parece más
atractiva y no creo que sea la mejor
manera de conocer a alguien pero sí
ronda 1 presentación
hola cómo estás estoy bien cómo estás la
vida es muy bella
cómo te llamas tienes hermanos bien mi
nombre es lis y tengo tres hermanos
menores bien siguen hola soy victoria
tengo dos hermanos menores que me llevan
ocho y diez años de diferencia y me
gusta jugar tenis
soy sabrina pero las personas me llaman
saps con una zeta
sí pero es diferente quiero ser
diferente la mayor parte del tiempo hago
saltos de tijera y tu hola mi nombre es
allana me encanta comer y qué quieres
decir con qué hace saltos de tijera
restaurante favorito esta semana está la
lechuga hola me llamo jonathan y me
encanta cantar en la ducha te gustan las
duchas
me encanta ducharme cuando te gusta
hacerlo una rápida por la mañana si
también me ducho por la mañana y por
cierto mi nombre es mi clic siendo
hispano soy hispana y te hablaré de mí
es difícil ser vegetariano en nuestras
culturas
soy guión a todos mis amigos me llaman
así con sus astas la canción que tú your
heart es una manera con la que puedes
recordarme
hombre me encanta comer y tengo dos
hermanos mayores son de esos hermanos
que siempre están cerca de ti cuando un
chico te pide una cita no se meten en
mis asuntos son independientes seres
cercanos a tus hermanos muy unidos es
por eso que soy un poco infantil pero a
la vez maduro pero muchas veces infantil
ronda 1 eliminación
jonathan debe eliminar a dos chicas de
la cita a ciegas
adiós me siento muy mal eliminaré a
curne
en realidad no pude conocerla desde el
principio y luego poco he salido con
chicas que tenían hermanos difíciles y
no resultó nada bien así que esas son
las dos razones
[Música]
ronda 2 la cita ideal
mi primera cita ideal y me gustan las
cosas casuales
así que ir a una cafetería a una
excursión me encanta el senderismo es
exactamente lo que a mí me gusta así me
gustaría que empezáramos con algo
pequeño como una excursión sí y luego si
todo va bien entonces te diría algo cómo
te gustaría ir a escalar oye me
encantaría adiós perfect bromeando
encanta la playa y me encanta el mar
hace tiempo que no voy así que creo que
sería genial creo que la mejor parte de
la cita es simplemente hablar me gusta
mucho conocer lugares pasear por algún
sitio y me encantan mucho los museos de
arte te gustan las citas individuales o
digamos una cita grupal o nunca he
estado en una cita grupal y nunca ha
tenido una cita doble así que eso podría
ser algo divertido de experimentar de
acuerdo
exacto sí si tú eres la que ama cantar
así que una pregunta cómo sería tu cita
ideal espera no creo que yo sea la que
le gusta cantar pero no hay problema oh
dios mío lo siento mucho está bien mi
primera cita ideal me encantaría hacer
algo en lo que podamos hablar pero
también en lo que hagamos
más o menos activo como un minigolf o
una partida de bolos todo lo que tenga
que ver con la comida me encanta todo lo
griego o cualquier cosa así que ahí es
que se vive más tiempo si se come comida
mediterránea eso dicen no en serio yo no
sabía si que vas a ser capaz de vivir
una vida muy larga cualquier cosa al
aire libre es realmente mi cita idea
suena como algo divertido de hacer eso
suena divertido
eso es genial espera eres director de
canto también tienes alumnos
bueno puede enseñarte también son bien
muy bien bien adiós pronto
ronda 2 eliminación jonathan debe
eliminar a dos chicas de la cita a
ciegas así que la primera que eliminar y
me disculpo de nuevo es briana la
energía supongo que es diferente
eso es somos dos energías diferentes me
gusta me clic me gusta que o no me gusta
yale
taiana
espero espero haber elegido la correcta
yo a odios ronda tres leyes los
obstáculos muy bien que rompe tus
esquemas cuando sales con alguien creo
que se trata de ser generoso con los
demás y ofrecerles un espacio abierto y
seguro si si alguien no lo hace para mí
es un gran obstáculo quiero que la
persona con la que vaya a tener una
relación sea capaz de darme esa
independencia sería alguien con poca
inteligencia emocional sería alguien que
dependiera demasiado de mí en la
relación muy bien por lo tanto no
podemos completar nos el uno al otro
pero podemos unirnos y crecer mutuamente
para mí un gran obstáculo es alguien que
no es honesto si no eres vegano no
quiero salir contigo y si estoy
bromeando estoy bromeando
soy vegana pero eso no es un problema
está muy bien por eso me encanta cómo
juegas vez eso es lo que te hace tan
especial es recibirlo si ronda 3
eliminación lo siento jonathan esta vez
tendrás que eliminar a 33 jonathan debe
eliminar a tres chicas de la cita a
ciegas de acuerdo
esto va a sonar mal pero que ona y la
razón es porque estamos aquí para tener
una relación pero me encantaría ser su
amigo creo que sería muy buena como
amiga
probablemente hill también
victoria afuera o dios tal vez si me
gusta victoria esto adiós
esto es me están presionando
ronda final objetivos de vida
me gustaría seguir viajando me encanta
viajar al extranjero
pero también me encantaría tener una
familia algún día
así que supongo que son dos qué quieres
decir con algún día cómo tener una
familia algún día es decir como en
cuántos años crees en quizá en los
próximos cinco haga lo que haga quiero
ayudar a las personas y sé que cuando
ayudó a alguien me siento muy orgullosa
de mí
[Música]
y por ahora soy estudiante en el tercer
año de licenciatura estoy estudiando
educación y mi objetivo es llegar a ser
profesora ronda final eliminaciones
jonathan debe elegir a una chica para
pedirle una segunda será que voy a
espero acertar con mis notas me siento
me disculpo pero me quedaré con liz
adiós
cómo te sientes ahora
bueno nunca he estado en una cita a
ciegas y es bastante las ciegas no he
ido a ninguna así que estoy un poco
nerviosa y también emocionada entonces
les gustaría conocer si quieres que nos
veamos ahora mismo quieres que nos
veamos más tarde
efe
puede ser ahora mismo
y nos dimos ese abrazo y yo estaba como
oh dios mío fue un poco incómodo al
principio porque es mucho para un
momento esto es emocionante es voy a
morderme por un momento y luego regresar
es por cierto lindos calcetines gracias
y así de un paso atrás para poder darle
espacio ahora podrás mostrarme los
movimientos que tienes cuando vayamos
cuando vayamos a a alcalá sí espero que
después de esto podamos intercambiar
nuestros números si ella está dispuesta
por supuesto depende de ella porque me
encantaría averiguar si hay química
basándome solo en la conversación así
que sí
[Música]
jubilee